seventy-eight players ok ok
this is nearly 19-hundred rated now for
the war zone Kings and a dead clock
already we're in the negative and is
this going to start out the same way no
I was thinking for a second why am I
going into this and that Bishop o light
squares are ripped apart that's me
how do you like that whoa that was quick
light square weaknesses g6 to play h6
and have to capture away from the center
there on g6 that's already busted
positionally what I was going to say is
ok now there's a dark square weakness on
d4 what I was going to say before the
tournament even started is what exactly
is that I don't know let's try this I
lost my train of thought there ok knight
c6 watch out for this on push might be
interesting
no Queen check clean check let me just
get this in Oh a mouse slipper let's try
it again I clean out my light square
Bishop needs to get working let's try
this oh they're gonna support it I'm
gonna sacrifice
with my tricky night and then opened
things up somehow this nights gonna land
in here isn't he yes he is he's much
trickier and then he's much trickier I
want to get out of oh they're giving it
they're giving it right back
let's do this
there could be Queen takes it could
definitely be Queen takes there let's
try this I get rid of their night-night
check okay Wow okay sixteen want the
Queen's off I want those Queens off they
are off I should have taken with the
pond maybe 14 seconds each over here
there's up here next maybe no matter
what I'm their rook here no matter what
King here give some checks checks
no time back to tournament 666 in a
bunch of two's okay sorry about that
clearing my throat there no time to mute
the stream to do that another is this
that this isn't the same guy that I
played before was it no way mate threat
f7 this looks very beginner like but um
I'm made to rather than f7 meter than f7
and b7 I see them along a diagonal Queen
takes here is interesting maybe
now just take that that rook Knight here
I take the knight Queen takes Knight I
take the rook getting material see this
from Queen h5 provoking g6 means this
guy is dead not seeing the world Queen
takes pawn and I could take another pawn
okay they resigned if the Queen blocked
I was gonna take another pawn on c6 and
then trade Queens actually I'd give
check on a and then when the Queen
retreats then I did exchange Queen so
that the King is less central not that
it really mattered cuz I was a bunch up
a bunch of material at that point so
this is like an advanced a better
version of an advanced French because I
have my LightSquared Bishop working so I
coordinate my pieces I need to get my
knight doing something I want Knight f5
Bishop e7 and here would be hitting this
pawn for a third time there might be
Knight a for stuff to c5 these support
points are we have to watch out for this
is hit twice there we go I think all the
way back is good stay off of this file
my rook wants to be here on this twice
I missed that the bishop when I played
here was blocking the Queen's view
bishop here looks you know what I would
do I would take the rook first that
happened me to complete my development
this pawn is gonna fall really don't
care about him though maybe I should
have cared about him pawn push next if
the knight moves I get a to clean trade
I need to get this pawn going he was
backwards if take side play here and
then I recapture with my no I do this
Knight here is gonna be pretty good stay
here because I want to guard my seventh
I have a time edge but they're playing a
very good game King towards the center
and break at their central point granted
he's now a weak link
King is central this is defended
they're out of play with their rook
let's do this
I should've done that let's run over
here that pod falls I don't have any
time back determine they played a very
good game twenty twelve twelve twelve
although okay I got that there's again a
good version of a French from that ok
Queen b3 pressure on b7 if Queen b6 c5 I
think I could do this because now I get
the rook I have to make sure my queen
Knight is developed in that variation as
otherwise there's Queen takes f4 Queen
to see one and I get mated they resigned
back to tournament 30 1212 bunch of 12s
2024 minutes remaining
c5 it's gonna move yes a night out
alright let's still go with this
grab some space b5 ok that Bishop has to
go back home he's not going back home
I'm up a piece I just want to complete
my development all right and then do
this next this nights gonna jump in here
but I have this square watch over this
it's weak he's ready to end up in a fork
take like this I don't want this pond to
be able to move because maybe the e-file
is opened up I don't want that to happen
rook right here oh what a bug let's do
this bishop here I don't want that to
happen
pawn push gonna have that pawn moving
yes we are okay so this is very poor
technique for starters for being up a
piece this is very very poor Bishop I
guess has to be here very very poor
technique right now okay I'm looking to
just give it back and then go into this
try and win this position try and win
this position four pawns four pawns two
three stop that card this I don't my
rook tethered to the defense of a pond I
need some time burners it's gonna be a
very important factor here who could
time burn okay rook might come back now
he's not going back
snakebite king in next back to
tournament 42 it's up a piece my bishop
was so stupid though he was a very bad
piece my pawns were all fixed on dark
squares and he was a dark square
traveler wasn't he okay some type of
Grand Prix oh my goodness that was a
flash of the adobe flash right there one
day I will actually follow through and
disable that right mouse-click I keep
saying I'll do that and I just don't do
it alright let's open this up that pawns
in a pin and now this is an issue this
pawn is hit twice we captured my bishop
he's not doing anything and it stops
castling granted my Queen would do that
as well the whole farm is now falling
bishops on my knight but there and check
that bishops in a pin pile up on it
double check if King takes here
still in a pen the bishops in a pen
still in a pen they missed that night
here actually rook takes probably no
matter what and then get the other rook
on the F file let's give a check first
King here and okay now this is wit
picking up our material and mate here if
the Queen goes too far like a four night
here and rook here next made threat
mates right here takes and then takes
here should take that deflect the Queen
away from that square that's me
56 30 28 tactic of deflection when one
of your opponent's pieces is having to
watch over another okay let's get some
center get some center
all right let's keep it closed here it
might be night here and take that trade
dark square actually I'm gonna take this
oops uh material my knight wants to be
back over here Oh dark square weaknesses
why would I do that
now watch over this I created too many
weaknesses just then Oh that pond is
just gonna fall
why didn't I defend it oh okay
can I somehow still get this here okay
hang on my brook here my knight here and
my Knight wants to be on f4 I'm seeing
I'm seeing a path somehow where is that
path making out of here for starters Han
take stuff
night here that's gotta be good here no
matter what
oh I didn't want to take that was a
mouse slip ah that was a bad Mouse slip
because that just gave them that rook
activity night checks bishops gonna come
here check I'm gonna give that up
oh they're getting that rook check is
still good surprisingly I actually have
that move time burners time burners
tricky night why wasn't I able to move
there well I actually got that actually
was working out in the end back to
tournament 72 forty to forty forty that
was such a bad mouth slip I wanted to be
six that rook came right to life pond
take spawn no way definitely didn't want
to do that it definitely didn't want to
do that okay let's get this Bishop out
and maybe I I shouldn't take the pin
piece I thought I was gonna do that and
then play e4 I should have played a
floor right away they could take this
pawn I think I get a lot of play they're
stopping me from queenside castling but
have two knights right in the center
back him up with that four and then I
play in the F file if he's taken okay
that's a lot of weaknesses right here
this square in particular he's stuck I
want a pile up here
even if he's removed this Bishop is bad
so pile up on this pond I could take
here cuz this pawn is pinned I should
have been considering that it's now
defended let's make sure he's going
nowhere
rook up and over there's some issues
here okay Queen here is no good what am
I even doing
let's try this again Queen here and then
Bishop takes okay let's try this let's
try this
it was my queen even doing just come all
the way back here probably no matter
what why did I like this why did I let
all this activity occur okay now I have
some lateral movement and I'm winning
this pawn counter-attacking move to
watch over g2 I do have that watch or
I'm on the bishop and grab here finally
come on here three times that is covered
g2 is covered trades they're down on
time back to tournament 90 90 56 54 54
okay a lot of time halfway point okay
all right let's grab some space more
space with tempo the knight has to find
a new home more space and more space
maybe if the knight place to f3
he's not doing that I could still maybe
do this if prepped a bit more I don't
have enough support for okay now that
position is closed rook pawn attacking
nights on b3 b6 and g3 g6
are often a good idea and now this is
big trouble bishop here's a fork here no
matter what so I could get my knight
into this square looking for this or
maybe better yet no it's good enough but
no okay I dude this move the King moves
I do this
the queen is close to trapped and I get
this and dark squares queenside castle
get on this point next on this
nights dead and we have May coming up in
three I think three or four on b2 right
seventeen they resigned back to term at
1:10 70 65 57 56 less than 15 for Smith
Maura when do I play this okay so this
is a Marazzi bind I don't know what the
big difference is with delaying the
capture on d3 pawn push coming up soon
actually there's a tactical shot okay
that Bishop is a big trouble Queen here
I should have done that too and do some
weaknesses stay on this diagonal may
takes bishop and queen close to trapped
isn't she it's another weakness can I
take advantage of them I'm gonna see
about that
don't really have to own let's take care
first thought I would have to retreat on
the queen who is unprotected okay I
don't have any time where'd my time go
where did my time go
Wow they are flying 35 seconds
okay get rid of that night get rid of
that night he's pinned okay if they
didn't do anything about that okay get
behind this pond nine seconds should be
plenty actually so I have a very clear
plan at this point
no stalemates its mate next back to
China at 1:30 88-83 um okay yeah see
five still let's try B five all right oh
my goodness it's going to cost me it's
going to cost me get some development
and get this night out of there get
developed
grab some space
okay it's not Mel slip well it's not mo
slip Knight c3 I'm on the Queen get my
other night working somehow get that
other night working and I was probably a
very poor decision by me to do that and
to take my bishop or are they my knight
should be able to land some tricky stuff
soon something tricky here
get this pond marching keep going he's
pushing through
he's definitely pushing through upon
promotion
sacking the house take one of them take
one of those Queens just want to get to
f3 it's gonna be me back to tournament
150 108 90 10 minute warning mm-hmm okay
efore french Benoni potentially benoni
structure oh I didn't have to do Bishop
to e2 because they wouldn't okay with
this structural change now this pawn is
passed let me remove this Knight and I
want to get in c4 I'm doing this
exchange because I want to get them in
c4 and have a connected passed pawn I
should have considered taking their
first let's do it now so this is an
asset and do this I do this pawn push
would have come soon and now this is
game over trade Queens and then this
Bishop is dead stay coordinated grab
this pawn double up next push this pawn
away too connected passed pawns I'm on
the rope
take care double stay coordinated and
then push keep marching
keep marching made soon Wow he's running
away
get over here get back here get back
here
ok back to Terra 170 122 108 103 9
minutes remaining nine minutes remaining
um 105 they resigned oh man
180 122 all right let's stay focused
here
stay focused it's gonna be challenged
fianchetto let's try feeing keto
opposite that Queen that pond pushes I
take here there's a Bev for night back
there's of D 2 and then C 4 happens now
this is big trouble oh very big trouble
queen is dead just like that it takes
Bishop here back to tournament 200 122
110 106 103 alright
Smits Mora decline that every time every
time I decline it most of the time most
of the time
let's keep this structure as is I want
my Jeep on to have to capture all my
piece is working it's a bit sensitive
the ship takes and then pond push this
nice killer how can I get rid of him now
to do that he has to go he's got to go
what take that no I think he's way too
dangerous to make sure he's out of there
take here I'm on the Queen first my rook
is hanging and oh man
that night's gonna kill me okay um I
should have taken the pun
it was my one moment to come back there
I need to get that pun oh my goodness
okay I'm on to Bishop flight square
eleven seconds
not a lot of time that's what you call
this we call this not a lot of time can
my tricky night do something dangerous
okay not really what I would have would
have liked to see their need to cut off
the communication need to cut off the
communication there throw that check in
four seconds
don't take the pawn whatever you do
don't take the pawn I need to pre move
like a maniac like a maniac for seconds
I take that pawn how much time
time burners
Oh back determine two 21:43 they were
down on time
two seconds remaining in that one
striker um kill this night and then play
e4 okay let me try and get a four and I
have a good Center I'm looking to push
that night around and that one was tense
that one was definitely tense get
developed break that pin actually I
don't know how great of a pin break that
was not so great not so great at all
pawn takes is very good no I have this
defended me take here my bishop is
defended my dark-squared bishop
so check just get right out of that push
that night around a little bit watch
over this guy it's very valuable Knight
takes pawn is there not anymore
Queenie for and do some more weaknesses
get that clean out of here I want to
keep my Queen on the board actually she
is close to trapped isn't she she's
close to trapped Bishop here Bishop f6
should okay crashing through on this
square there oh wait the night could
play there they resigned back to
tournament 241 5150 they had 96 oh I
know I actually I had I had Queen to h8
as well I missed that
Queen AJ or g7o resignation to 51 54
minutes remaining
alright last two maybe three if there's
not any quick resign errs I could maybe
look to work with this structure okay
Queen Queen e2 and I could get that move
in if I really want to I'm not gonna do
it just yet okay with this structural
change I want my pawn on c4 I want to
stop these guys from advancing okay
we're having this this Bishop is still
struggling still struggling let's do
this I'm not sure why I can't explain it
just yet pawn pushed next I've pressure
on this [ __ ] up I was missed on the
Queen Bishop is stuck that Bishop is
officially stuck he's freed up at this
pitch this pawn is dead now so get this
guy rolling keep pushing him as far as
you can guard him with the bishop next
and then get the rook to b8 hang on
watch out for those Primo's the sneaky
Primos
just in time there
then come after the weak links over here
watch out for stalemate this guy's past
let's get him rolling no no no back here
crack through at that pond now in this
direction the stepladder stepladder time
okay back to Turman 272 ten two minutes
remaining
the oh this guy this guy's in the second
place slot dragon okay I don't play this
often I don't play this often
alright I'm dropping 87 dropping my
LightSquared Bishop but me I could have
done that okay I'm picking up their dark
square Bishop gotta take that I'm on f4
if I could get f4 it's big trouble
- for my Knights looking to get here
maybe I should have taken that right
away take it now so now dark squares
night here my knight is pinned it's come
over here to defend the pawn pawn here
night here defense c7 the pawn push ok
I'm actually a little happy to see that
it's spending too much time there hog
push stop that pod now they helped out
my rook helped up my rook right there my
bishop looks like a very stupid piece
maybe he is maybe he is do I have that
back rank mates if the rook defends I'm
gonna get this guy so my other pawns can
finally move ok still quite difficult to
win this ending opposite color bishops
on their pond okay I got another pawn at
this guy rolling
I think they calmed the tournament this
game isn't even gonna finish yeah it
didn't finish that was a really strong
game - this guy was in second place I
think yes
- 7210 204 201 83
alright warzone Kings good games